so among the many lies it's hard even to
keep track of all the lies but Joe
Biden's DHS secretary has told us
repeatedly the border is completely
secure
but now the chief of the border patrol
just contradicted that in the Stark as
possible terms for that story Fox's
Trace Gallagher joins us now hey Tracy
hey Tucker he could not have been more
clear if he stood on top of the Paseo
Del Norte bridge in El Paso and yelled
Liar Liar it is a quadruple blow to the
Biden administration because border
patrol Chief Raul Ortiz defied DHS
secretary Alejandro mayorkas and
President Biden by saying this does DHS
have operational control of our entire
border
no sir you heard the secretary he said
we have operational control that's the
definition based upon the definition you
have sir up there no we don't have
operational control no sir
and there was more Chief Ortiz also said
the border is not secure he defended
horseback agents who President Biden
accused of whipping Haitian migrants and
then he offered a final spike in the
heart boss simultaneously coming after
this Administration and supporting the
previous administration saying it was a
mistake to stop building the wall
Trump's wall Chief Ortiz also pleaded
for Congress to give him more border
agents and ask for the tools to deliver
consequences that's important right
because for 26 months millions of
migrants have crossed the border and
received zero consequences the chief
told lawmakers this fiscal year alone
000 illegal immigrants have evaded
Border Patrol Those are people that
border agents tried to catch but didn't
you know the gotaways and an additional
79 000 snuck into the country completely
undetected the final blow might be the
chief's language where contrary to
secretary mayorkas Ortiz referred to the
Border situation situation as a quote
crisis much more on this tonight on Fox
News at night Tucker
thanks so much for that story
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight